I mean do you remember the first time
you heard about Space Command oh my god
oh well no I don't what I could tell you
what you wanted into if you think it is
I'm talking about her life forever you
know but uh but I I actually don't
remember what when did you first hit me
up with her alright I just kind of well
you know it's funny because the Space
Command it evolves over a period of time
it was basically you know as I said
start Star Trek was really the formative
moments in my life once when Star Trek
gave you the first episode was the
mantrap
it aired when I think Star Trek debuted
when I was 10 years old and and it was
the thing I've been waiting all my life
for it really brought everything
together and and I think from from the
moment that I've had the making of Star
Trek when I was 13 I decided I wanted to
be a showrunner I wanted to create and
run my own science-fiction show and all
the hundreds of hours of television I
did all the books I wrote were all
toward learning that gaining those
skills that I would need to be able to
do that thing and when the lane like got
together I mean we did together for 40
years we've been married for 39 she was
a terrific director she always been a
director off Broadway she already been
an actress she was a wonderful writer
and so on some projects we would
collaborate on other projects we would
work individually over the years but
clearly with Space Command as obviously
I would need her skill set and and we
both loved working with actors we love
working with editors and I love visual
effects artists I love concept designers
and so forth so I've been gathering a
team and so from the beginning I knew I
wanted to work with the line on this
project the campaign off point was we
were feeling both feeling very disturbed
about the dark and cynical turn that
science fiction had taken yes and he
introduced me well I can find you a
little bit of rapport but he was a great
fan of things like Space Patrol and it
was where you know bad things happened
but good people with good people what
we'll straight just to judgments
integrity space patrol was a science
fiction show that aired live in the
1950s and I didn't grow up watching it
but in the 1980s
us a cable I had a show called night
flight and they ran kinescopes of that
show that kinescopes was filmed
basically
put a camera 16-millimeter camera on a
height like a high-resolution TV screen
as the show was broadcast live and you
record it on film and those were called
kinescopes and so they were airing those
kinescopes of space command and it was a
wonderful show it came before Star Trek
but it had great sense of adventure and
later I met the star of the show head
camera who actually been a pilot in
World War two he worked p-51 Mustang had
been shot down he was captured by the
Germans escaped from a German POWs camp
he was a real hero before he played a
science fiction hero in the night and he
looked like when he was like very
handsome man and so so that was part of
the inspiration and then of course Star
Trek and and when Elaine was talking
about the dark science fiction there's a
period a few years ago where all the
science fiction was very dark and varied
this topic whether it was Battlestar
Galactica which I very much liked or
Elysium or after earth or any of these
things they all were saying the future
is going to be really bad there's not
anything you can do about it and people
and must have mean certain things don't
work out lies and what was odd or what
my pointed out what was odd was it
disappeared by writers his life is
pretty darn good it all goes in families
rather than challenge anyone plus
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
millions of dollars so somehow there was
a disconnect between the life they were
creating personally and the work they
were writing and I felt very strongly
that science fiction outer limits
Twilight Zone Star Trek those shows had
a moral compass and they and
particularly Star Trek said the future
is going to have challenges Star Trek we
shot during the civil rights movement
during the Vietnam War and yet it said
the future is going to have challenges
but we can reach across boundaries and
barriers and come together to create
something better and I thought that was
very important too to say now and some
of it is not just about science the
objective of storytelling I mean if we
assume that most people have kind of a
hard life and somebody in the family's
mentally ill somebody is on substances
and there's a struggling you work hard
and you go and you watch a story and it
says well things are really dark and
awful and you don't have any hope and
the Thals into the hell these people is
that really responsible stand to take or
do you want your audience to go out of
there and say
okay struggle but people can come out on
top people are basically good at heart
if you just give them a shot and you
give people a sense when they leave that
Peter that there's possibility
it just seems far more accurate and
socially responsible and just put them
on a downer well you know if we're
looking an extremely powerful medium you
know television reaches millions of
people around the world if you do it
right it lasts forever
most the shows I've written for is still
being watched even the ones that I wrote
when I was in my early 20s and and so
there's there's a question that many
writers never ask themselves which is as
far as I can tell which is am I actually
creating something that's making the
world a better place
am I actually sending out a message that
I would want people to take to heart you
know TV can do one of three things it
can either anesthetize or fill people
with despair or inspire people and I
think the first obligation of any
dramatic entertainment is to entertain
obviously if you don't entertain you
know it doesn't matter what your message
is people will stick around for it but
beyond that once you entertain people
once you bring them into your world and
they love that world and want to be part
of that world then if you can say well
you know take these lessons take what
you've seen a story take it out of the
real world take it out into your life
you can actually have a better life you
can make a better world I think those
are very important messages to
communicate not an airy-fairy you know
like not not sugarcoat anything these
people don't like to be lied to and they
know anything lied to like oh
everybody's happy at least you know but
but but if you within a real context
where you say okay things are hard you
get into a bad mood you say the wrong
thing but you can be be man enough to
apologize you know that none of the time
two things you like to address yeah
you